well hello to bros hi hi
hi good to see you guys where are we
mental health-wise right now because
it's we're what almost 10 of this thing
i am as anxious as can be how are you
i um you know it's crazy because we've
been in this situation for so long
the normal stressors that happen in
normal life
um i i think are now all
piling up on each other on top of what i
guess we're calling out
the twin democ because we're talking
about covid
and we're talking about flu season right
yeah it's crazy
my brain is gonna explode for a second i
thought you were taking a dig at your
own children
i did too okay you want to know
something i have to be
perfectly honest they i like the two of
them the most out of
everything you heard it here first it's
no you heard it i'm tired
i've been saying it for years it's true
it could change
i like the winds in santa ana this this
too shall pass
but i'm just saying that i they have
become max and nicki are like at that
very cool age where they're
you know sorry humans and cool and you
can talk to them
and they're interesting and interested
and it's really it's fun it's a great
set they just turned 17
last week yeah great age yes happy
belated birthday
and i've been listening to i'll give it
to you stradish and
heather you've raised a child wise
beyond her years
i am learning things for you and i am a
good decade plus
older thank you what's it been like to
see the response to this show that you
really
made happen when the world was shut down
yeah i mean it's crazy it was very cool
that this was
somewhat born out of your public coming
out which the response to that was
pretty incredible it was really cool to
see how positive everything was
how did it feel to sit in there because
i know your mom was like
once i post this it's gonna be a thing
yeah but then it was a thing so what was
the leg
to take all that in i didn't really
expect it i went a lot bigger than i
thought it would but
it was honestly like very empowering
and i never thought like i'd be able to
have a platform where i can help people
you know my age especially and so people
reaching out to me and
telling me all that it's just really
cool yeah i think you probably helped
more people than you know
by doing it because getting those
conversations started but what was it
like in your own world because i know
you go to a catholic school
um and the religion is not always the
most accepting
of lgbtqia so what was it like to
process that
in your own bubble in your own world and
we're jewish
yeah yes well we're boo jews at a
catholic school
in orange county yeah buy boo jews at
the catholic school yeah
so in my own bubble at my school in my
world coming out was
i did not know what to expect i honestly
there was a thought in me i was like
you're gonna get expelled
you're not going back to school which is
a possibility it's you know things like
that have happened
at schools like mine but um everyone was
super
super positive and i got a text actually
from
the principal's son and he was like hey
i'm
so proud of you blah blah and i was like
thank you so much don't you dare tell
your dad
and he told me he goes so of course not
and then an hour later i get a text from
him so my dad saw the article on people
[Laughter]
here goes i was like this is gonna be a
really good college essay
but no he he was totally excited he's
like my dad loves everyone he loves you
like you're amazing you're fine don't
even worry about it i have to say the
culture of her school
is really beautiful and very
encompassing and we've been really proud
it's been super cool but even with max's
permission to talk about this
i can only tell what it's like as a
parent which is great
and i get tons of messages about it but
for max to be telling her story
from her age vantage point
is just it's like worth gold i'm just so
so proud of her
thanks yeah a lot of the the praise at
the time was heaped on your parents for
doing
a very good job oh good job you did the
bare minimum
hey i birthed you yeah she did 20.
she birthed you and created an
environment where you felt comfortable
enough to come out when you did
what would you say to kids who are maybe
not
at a house that's so accepting and i
always say live your truth be happy
be yourself but you know take
precautions and
really take into account how this will
affect your like life and you need a
place to live and stuff
there's a lot of resources online and i
think the most important thing
is that is communicating love and that
you want to be accepted and
even if they don't understand it they
can still love you and be there for you
and support you even if they
didn't grow up understanding the like um
being bisexual or being gay or anything
like that
i love this kid this kid is so cool and
if somebody doesn't have
a friend they can turn to max to bros
dms are open
oh yeah i checked i check all of them i
have no life
okay i will respond the dms has anybody
slid into the dms are we dating since
publicly coming out i have dated since i
came out
but i am way too anxious to date
also definitely have commitment issues
way too independent for anyone but
i have people have slid into the dms i'm
not going to lie
um but i'm to date in a pandemic
and especially because i don't like
leaving my house but and there's that
and i don't really like people
so and see she has a lot of her dad and
her yeah
but terry's the weird combination of
doesn't love people but loves attention
oh yes
it's called a narcissist
but you gotta you have a pretty good
house to be trapped in all this stuff oh
oh yeah listen oh trust me look we're
very grateful i mean if you got to be
quarantined this is a good place to be i
agree
but we're building another house in
idaho
yes yep would we permanently move to
idaho
you know i i mean never say never you
know i keep getting this question a lot
too
would you no i'm we're not moving to
idaho don't even we're not moving
i'm going to tell you something idaho is
so beautiful yeah and i haven't been
there what i really love about this
place that we're building
i want to leave the kids have a place to
go to like when things are great
or when they need to hide or when they
need some alone time or they're going
through a transition or
just happy or whatever it is i want them
to have like some
other place to go and i think that's
idaho for us aka it's a summer house
that
we are gonna take over when they die
like that yeah yeah practical you're
very practical max
definitely and we built a podcasting
room or we're
it's in the plans well you hinted on
instagram that maybe some more projects
are coming up for the
family you've been kind of
cagey about what it is but it is not you
won't say for sure it's a family reality
show but would you guys want to do a
family
family reality show um i think that
you know if there were a time to do
something like that
it would this would be a good time you
know the timing would probably be better
now than it was
you know even three or four years ago
all right hypothetical family reality
show what was the ideal kind of show be
what would we see you guys do what would
you want to do
you're very stuck on this price what's
very funny is that i was thinking about
that i was like you know if we did have
that or whatever
what would they watch me do sit in my
room
right um this is what i would say i
would say
and then you don't have to agree this is
what i would say i would say that
each of the four kids and terry and
myself
are all in interesting um periods of
life right now
all six of us at weird crossroads in
completely different ways
and it could be a fun thing to watch i'm
not saying that we're gonna do a show
like that
but if we were to i think it could be a
fun thing it's a hard thing
to want to pull the trigger on because
you know we've all done and you know
terry and i have been there before we
know what the
the dark side of all of that is and so
it's not something we would take lightly
and the other thing is you know anytime
someone says stay tuned
big things coming it may happen never
happened whatever
but what i can tell you is that during
this whole
pandemic um great family time
honestly uh and irritating the crap out
of each other at times for sure
but also some very interesting creative
things have come out like max's podcast
there's a lot of like fun cool things
hopefully
when the world is you know opening back
up again we're going to be able to
continue
and see how those things all pan out so
i hope it does and you know
i will be calling you first oh yeah you
better
all right i'll ask you one more question
maybe it'll be a two-parter here about
this
hypothetical maybe family reality show
would it be maybe at a network that you
have other shows on
would it be a streamer would it be
something you guys would want to
have control over because you know
there's a a big family giving up their
reality tv mantle on said network
yeah that is true so there could be
there could be white space
um so i what i would say is
it's at this point we don't know yeah
okay
i can i will i will take that all right
your former reality show yes real
housewives of orange county
i know you've seen the memes and the
comments like heather
you were so right we should have
listened to you what is your reaction to
seeing
you know three plus years later that
response
uh well you know you know i don't watch
the show but one of the funniest things
i did see
was tamara sent me a meme and it said
somewhere in orange county heather
dubrow is sitting in her
mansion drinking champagne and laughing
that she was on the you know something
like that right and so tamara said this
to me and i
happen to be sitting in the kitchen with
a glass of champagne we were drinking
terry and i were having dinner and i
took a selfie of myself
and i sent it back to her and we were
cracking up i thought it was so funny
you know i think that
reality shows and housewives they just
need to
keep moving forward and evolving
and you need new characters and things
always work out for a reason and the way
they're supposed to
i honestly i you know i have no
i'm not sitting here going i'm so
i don't care you know what i think the
show is actually
still doing well i'm so proud to be i
have
have been a part of pop culture and the
franchise and
and i'm glad that i've moved on i was
gonna say are you happy to
maybe not have been a part of the show
at this very
controversial time between the pandemic
and everything that happened over the
summer and
having to deal with that on camera i
think it was very clear during my last
season on the show that
that the tides were turning and the show
was becoming something different than i
had originally
started on five seasons earlier and um
so obviously that was the right time for
me to go and it
and it's evolved into whatever it's
involved into so
um i'm glad it wasn't a choice that i've
during this time you've really navigated
the changing waters of content
your whole career because you've gone
from really traditional media
to reality tv to just kind of owning the
digital space and
the podcasts it's like this it's a
similar podcast for two different
generations because you talk about some
of the same topics have you ever stolen
topics from one another no but i'm going
to start doing that
great idea but we've been on each
other's shows and i think that was
really cool and
will you come back on my show again soon
i will i would love that
[Music]